[Music]
from kansas city to the carolinas the
nation has a wide variety of barbecue
styles
well it's time to add another to the
list nashville style that's what
restaurateur will newman is cooking up
at four locations of edly's barbecue
a chain named for his grandfather and
named by
thrillist as among the best in the city
what's going on folks how y'all doing
nashville style barbecue is at the heart
of edly's
a place where locals come and pork
sandwich
with their children and dogs looking for
that southern goodness
look at that that makes this place
unique that looks so good
dishes like avocado barbecue nachos with
your choice of protein
brisket lasagna fried pickles and a hot
chicken sandwich
shake off the oil owner will newman says
he likes doing things
differently a lot of places here deep
fried and toss it in a type of
cayenne based juices we have our own hot
chicken rub
gives it a really cool flavor okay so
we're both going for the same
take take the punishment yes the
punishment
you ready i'm ready
so the way we create these you don't
typically find the heat on your tongue
or your lips hot chicken sandwich up
and it builds with each bite so the
first bite
is very approachable you're like oh this
isn't too bad before too long
my bald head will be sweating pretty
good
as for the sides they're given as much
attention
as the meat the mac and cheese is our
most popular side it's got a
gouda base to it we went very high
quality ingredients
on the mac we're just as proud of our
sides as we are our meats
but don't get it twisted the star of
newman's most inclusive table
has thoroughly been through the smoker
in the south
barbecue means smoking the meat it takes
12 hour process to smoke our meat we're
using
white oak and everything here has been
smoked and what does smoking do
smoking just infuses a flavor
that is just so different and distinct
than you would find if you just did it
on an open traditional grill or a flat
top you're bringing in the flavor of the
wood
enriches just the flavor of the meat and
so we want to make sure it's completely
submerged yes the other flavors come
from the seasoning
pit master ut craven showed me just how
it's done with this nashville pork butt
on the platter on the platter the code
to barbecue is you can't take shortcuts
and it has to be very humble and you let
the meat
speak for itself and what you're going
to do is flip that joint over check the
access off
there you go yeah you barbecued i'm glad
i worked out this morning there you go
right there like that good good
everywhere so there is no rest for the
pit master
there is no rest for the pit master we
start cooking tonight for tomorrow
anything else the memphis native was no
stranger to barbecue
if you're born in memphis there's
something stamped in your dna
about barbecue it was part of our family
we talked about barbecue everywhere we
went we went to small barbecue joints
a tradition he's passing on to his kids
it's good
but his first foodie experience out of
college do these need any sides
wasn't what you'd expect i bought into a
homemade
ice cream franchise and you owned like
two of them right yeah we had one in
atlanta and one in nashville and it was
a great way
for me to learn business and how to
manage people and then you said
um i think i want to go to law school
yes
i met my wife here in nashville wanted
to impress her
yes i chased her to birmingham and then
figured out law school that i want to be
a lawyer
that had this crazy idea to open up a
barbecue joint in nashville
together in 2011 they opened edly's
barbecue
one of music city's most beloved down
home eateries
there's a dynamic feeling in the air
that you feel in nashville
and so we wanted to try to find a way to
infuse that
into our barbecue no visit to edly's
would be complete i'm told without at
least
a sip of this it's our bushwhacker the
best way to describe the bushwacker is
think of the adult
frosty from wendy's but it's all kinds
of goodness has been added to it
lots of madness lots of rum cream to
cocoa
coffee liqueur some vanilla and milk and
then some 151 to top it off
bushwackers are our staple people come
from all over for the bushwacker
so good let me see set it down which way
right there on the bottom
people are coming back though many never
left
take out was a strong business for them
during lockdown
no matter how bad things were in our
past we're always going to inch forward
and you know at least is still moving
forward and moving onward and upward
and i learned something i never seen a
pork butt before
nice job with the butt thank you you did
a great job really well good
and then there's this little puppy right
here the bushwhacker
swacker i want to thank jess marcy
sue whoever brought this to the table
because this comes out of a machine at
least so take a sip everybody take a sip
[Music]
and you know what whoa i mean it's got
some action in there
that packs a punch well thank you and i
will fill in any time
just keep them come back for bushwackers
anytime elaine yes i'll be here
all right thank you michelle